yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is about some new products
available on chasuble in particularly
the one that I wanted to yeah focus on
but when I get locked onto testable to
go to this course that I wanted to tell
you about that so that there are some
other new things release also very
interesting just briefly mentioning
because I can tell you something about
those books as well this video is mostly
about Yusupov courses the fundamentals
build up your chest we're going to get
that like in a minute I just want to
mention that there are some other cool
releases on chasuble there are nice
invisible chest moves is a very good one
there is a book that was released some
years ago was it's some years ago and
its really really delightful
it's about unusual chess solutions it's
a really nice one
then strategic chest exercise is also
very good by a man with a brick ah it's
a book that I used except extensively in
my chess lessons and there's also game
changer on chasuble the big book on
alpha zero and it's here also in paper
and this is something that I will make a
video on very soon - it's just like it's
very complex and it's not something that
can do off the bat so there are a couple
of new cool things on chasuble but it's
mostly about this one the fundamentals
build up your chest by Yusupov I'm going
to click on it and um yeah the Yusupov
books as they usually called are really
an absolute cornerstone of my my chess
lessons my whole chess teaching Yusupov
has released more books but this is like
his core work and there are in total
nine books it's 3 times 3 there are 3
books catered to a level like
fifteen hundred three books up to
eighteen hundred and three books up to
two thousand one hundred I have the
paper books I can show you some here
yeah this is the German version these
are the three books catered towards
getting to fifteen hundred in German and
they have this very cool title I think
Tiger Shuang the tigers leap to 1500 is
the title basically if you translate it
one to one in English they've chosen
kind of a weird naming scheme and ever
really got it
I think the Tigers leap to 1500 is just
like a cool title but they decided on
something else so what is this we have
three books that should get you to a
rating to 1500 and the first of those
books that would be the this one the
number one yep this is now available on
chasuble the first one of this whole
this whole work so it is about
fundamentals that means if you really
study all the books starting with this
one you're supposed to get the
fundamental knowledge of chess that
should get you to this roughly this
rating level I have to say that it's a
really a mixed bag in terms of
difficulty there are some things in then
I feel are probably known to many 1,400
players or 1300 players but there are
also some concepts in there that are
useful for that playing level but will
get you get you far let's say with
information that you can use up to a
really high level actually of play funny
a thing that I need to mention is that
you may be recently saw a game by the US
Champion Sam Shanklin who resigned the
game against onigiri in a drawn position
theoretically no one fortress position
that is a draw and this position is like
one-to-one with one irrelevant
extra porn is part of the 1500 Tigers
sleep so if Sam would have yeah I mean
okay you just had a blackout you know
but what I'm trying to say is that there
are also some concepts in that are
reasonably advanced I have I've seen
myself some exercises in those books
that I could not like solve a the
incident I really had to think about it
for a moment so um if you are even rated
1500 or 1600 it is absolutely a good
idea to look through them so in chess
about how does that work we have all
those chapters and it's here 20 26
chapters in the book it's it's the same
kind of the same kind of order of
chapters we have an intro chapter and
then we've got a couple of you can read
that right yeah I think it's possible
and then you've got all those chapters
here mating motifs basic opening
principle simple porn endings piece
value opposition centralization so there
is a combination of tactical motifs that
are really really important at that
level and also some yeah some more
advanced and more general concepts so
what I like about the books it's it's a
very well-rounded approach you get you
get calculation and tactics but you also
get some strategic introductions yeah -
to chest that a little bit more than
just like I take this he takes that I
take that have a piece of which is super
important on any level but having some
chapters like weak points for example or
centralization what is called
centralizing the pieces this is very
very important so then it's a
combination a lot of things
I myself have used those books
absolutely I mean so often
Kjell so they are super useful in
training yourself and training also
teaching others and ingestible you have
one advantage practical advantage over
the books if you look at the books I'm
going to just make the direct comparison
they have always per chapter and they
have some let's say games or positions
that demonstrate the point that they
were making introducing motifs
introducing ideas and concepts and and
then there are some exercises about this
particular subject it has a typical
problem of any kind of exercises that
you have in book say for example I'm
going I'm just going to show you on the
camera and you yam in the book you have
like six diagrams per page and then you
can solve them and then if you want to
look the solution up maybe you only want
to look at two positions or three you
don't have time for all of them and then
you want to look up the solution you
will be invariably spoiler there because
you see everything is on one page every
solution is on one page and this is of
course much much more refined on chesil
if you go into any particular subject of
course I can do learn next and then it
goes through it like an e-book step by
step but I just want to show how how it
basically looks like you would have the
exercises and then you can exercise say
let's say click here and say solve and
then it gives you the position and then
you can solve that ingestible you're not
spoiler yeah here I would be very
surprised if it isn't d5 so I can play
d5 at this d5 I think I've looked at
this a lot so yeah now we're probably
going to take or do we have something
strong the check no we're going to take
and now rookie one looks very
good-looking one yeah and we we have
managed we've gotten some points so that
then we get all the all the texts with
all possible alternatives and so on so
like with any book adaptation in
chasuble that has exercises it works
very well here yeah you have all the
positions one by one and you can solve
the exercises and it is really quite a
bit bit of material it's not just like
we go to I'm sorry to browse again we
have 25 I think in general chapters and
then there is also a final test that
only have some exercises every single
chapter like 25 chapters has 12
exercises so you have like 225 12
you've got like 300 almost there
exercises so and which is really a lot
and so you learn a lot and you have a
very as I said a good range good
overview of subjects so it's some kind
of really what it is saying in the title
build up your chest and its fundamentals
it's kind of but everything is based
upon as mentioned um the original books
like in German they say up to rating
1500 to get to 1500 if you are already
on 1500 or even 1600 it is not a bad
idea to look through that stuff it can
be very useful um and there will be
again some things that you know but many
things that you don't know I'm
absolutely sure I'm 100 percent sure for
example there are the so-called simple
porn endings and I guarantee you if you
have like 15
1,600 you will not solve all the 12 just
like that it's not going to happen I've
even taken some of those positions and
give them to people with 2,000 it's not
like they did that quickly this is
something that also needs to be
emphasized if you have exercises that
are a little bit simpler like compared
to your rating it doesn't hurt to do
them I mean if you're ready with every
single one say okay this one okay so
this one solved solved this is exercise
it's helpful to really get some things
so much into your system that you're
almost like instantly see things so
don't worry if you're a little bit
higher rated it's still a good exercise
I've recommended that for example the
1500 1500 exercise I recommended that to
people who have 18 1,900
just as an exercise program before
events like Championships because you
get some exercise in which is not super
challenging but it gets you it gets you
warmed up and you will see the odd thing
that you have not seen before so I think
it works very well on Chesham oh the
whole thing and you also get a starting
discount for a couple of days I think I
would need to look out if we I'm looking
out now yeah still for seven days you
get it a little bit cheaper for
twenty-five dollars so it's a nice 20
percent roughly 20 percent discount on
the unusual starting price I think it's
very very helpful even if you have the
books already it can be helpful to do it
on chesil simply because the whole
practice is is easier and if you're
interested in the course I will also put
a link in the video description and yeah
you settling I'm not going to earn any
money of it but just will we see how
many people come from my show which
would be probably useful statistics so
click there in the description and check
out the course
you're interested thanks for a lot for
watching and by the way I'm also doing
as mentioned a video on the game changer
book that will come in the next couple
of days will not be long yeah again
thanks for watching